what is going on there reject Nation we
are gonna watch Brooklyn nine nine leave
a like that's all we ask and a comment
and also share the video and tell all
your friends about it then afterwards
pledge to our patreon page upgrade your
pledge at the end of the month before
the automatic renewal charge happens
that would be a splendid idea also send
us a gift in our P.O box then after that
go tell your mother about us and if you
don't like it I mean let me say that
again if she doesn't like it
you know
eating mother stomp on her leg Yeah
[Music]
Mom can you lay here for just a second I
want to show you something that's how we
roll here at the real rejects all right
let's do it
[Music]
the suitcase of mystery no one alive
today knows its content Captain Holt has
finally given me permission to auction
it off I'll give you a massage Charles
going in the wrong direction and getting
himself disqualified
that's okay you tried I'll show you a
picture of me in high school there's a
side pony oh
I'll go on a date with you sold to Jake
not to Scully that really freaked me out
and I just want this to end now
Oompa Loompa so there's this suitcase
yeah
[Music]
a funny Beatrice Stephanie Beatrice
[Music]
Beatrice television happened commutes
were difficult boy I had a dream I laid
a goose egg on this that's enough a pipe
burst in the 9-8 rendering the building
uninhabitable they'll be sharing our
space until the problem is fixed oh [ __ ]
but sadly Boyle and I are gonna be on a
Stakeout all week yeah just two best
buds thinking up a Saturn with our
druthers of tunes and personal pan
pizzas oh I want one don't worry sir we
will be cordial AF ask Frazier I love
that show they're here
I hate those nice guest stars these guys
are the worst hey Stevie Shillings
Jakey pee in the place oh my God
put on your parkas because this week
just got a whole lot more chill out
allow me to introduce Stevie Chillin
chillins he was my very first partner in
one of the all-time greats takes one to
no one man come on Damien wins Damon
Damon Wayans Jr they win Junior yes my
first partner was also pretty cool
everyone called us Chucky and the cute
oh no
so I guess we all had great partners
that we've completely moved on from
because here's dad of old age he did
anyway we should motor oh a lot of down
time for inside jokes would you like
some milk what would you like some milk
the kind because you look like do you
like the milk please what's it from
pookies
[Laughter]
please clap we should work the case
together the BT Boys reunion tour
tagline boys will always be boys no wait
some boys never change no way Boys to
Men back to boys
Captain why are you doing this you hate
people in your space since I'm an
easygoing chat I once saw you use a
ruler to measure another ruler it was
all five centimeter it never should have
been in circulated
true you can borrow mine Terry knows his
keyboard shortcuts just deleted
everything no
Ryan brought a dog with him and my
allergies are going crazy I'm so stuffy
I can't even enjoy that new binder smell
but I can hear you I have mild foot pain
okay Francie helps me with that how
legally you're not allowed to ask me
that my new desk mate
chess now I like to think of this little
lady oh no she also likes to look up
recipes online and go who's who's got
the time defund the police yes waste why
don't you both just move and work from
my desk everything's gonna be fine
I just took my whole computer
don't worry there's nothing on it
Phoebe's been tracking ozer off longer
than we have and three heads are better
than two he's a crowd everybody knows
that well what about in The Lion King
when's Jamon and purboy become friends
with Steamboat that's not the names it's
Simba team
where did the drive-in in a car
destination drug dealers bar passed the
mic right over to Charles we forgot
Charles no no don't be mad okay we need
you to work this case with us and you're
way too good for Paul stop trying to
flatter me Jake face it I'm not a beachy
boy all right well then neither am I the
bitsy boys are finished
what's the gossip if you can't stand
being in your office with him can you no
oh I'm just curious about your life I
like to gab
you just say the word and I will barge
in there and kick that dude out but more
to the point he's a welcome guest and I
am a good host he locked you out of your
own office didn't he yes very much oh
Raymond Raymond wrapped check it out guy
entering wait I know that dude he buys
from mozer off I say we gear up and we
bust in like we did at bakala
Restaurante remember
[Music]
oh yeah
that's how we do it in Brooklyn
that's that's pretty cool if we bust in
there and ozroth doesn't have any drugs
our whole operation is blown he never
works out of one place for long I
guarantee you he has drugs on him and if
we don't get him now we never will well
too bad for you because Jake agrees with
me we're always on the same
page yes totally actually Charles I
think Steve is right no you said Paige I
know but he knows this case and I trust
his gut but hey let's go catch a bad guy
together Boyle's gonna be right I'm
trying to drown up a sound of Ellen in
the chat Factory over there my daughter
got me a juicer for Christmas did you
know that you could juice nuts
your dog is a fraud come on draw a dog
frog dog frog dog
and they're not very considerate guests
and they took my mouse and then they
took my keyboard and then they took the
whole computer and when I had nothing
else to give they came from my yogurt oh
no
now they have to use the toaster oven
enjoy your 16-minute cook times idiots
guys
it's amazing back off it's our microwave
ours hey
the 9A stuff is blocking the windows
they can't see us out here this could be
our new beginning
there is to work outside but I could use
some adrenaline a little slap slap boom
what's left side boom Oh it's just this
thing we used to do to get each other
pumped up where we slap each other in
the face you don't have to do it no I
want you I want to go first
there's movement
NYPD show me your hands hey those are
off I have a martini with a Twist The
Twist you're under arrest none for me
I'm driving you to jail that's clean
there's no drugs on him damn it we
wasted those cool lines on nothing also
we blew the case that's obviously much
worse that was my first thought
this whole operation is blown you ask me
the beatsy boys should be called the
thoroughly messed up Millies oh oh
you're pissed but I am telling you
ozarov is dirty maybe but if we had
staked the bar out we could have built
up cases against a dozen guys here this
place is filled with criminals I brought
him in last month hater type of oil
we have grounds to search ozarov's home
it boils the one who pointed it out he
deserves a credit prot good job Earl you
know my name is Charles
that means chairs desks printers pins
but we gotta sneak it out so we need a
distraction okay here's what I'm
thinking we give that dog a bunch of
chocolates it dies
scotkins color just set fire to the
kitchen sink oh boy oh boy perfect let's
use that
either this guy's a drug dealer or he's
Nick Cage's interior designer might be a
drug dealer but we have nothing on him
quick question guys why did the drug
dealer never do his dishes because he
had drugs in his dishwasher oh snap
hello hey what's up dude it's me we got
the drugs man hang on Charles wants to
say hi do you have any milk no it's
beautiful never heard the printer sound
so happy I feel like it knows we did it
a new world
hahaha
we love it we're proud of you we want in
no you're acting like little children
playing basketball who've fallen behind
by several two-pointer buckets
yeah it's finished their arrest reports
Santiago did the filing of 10 minutes I
don't want to hear it just clean up this
mess and get back inside what the hell
you're just mad cause you're office you
do some research what we're gonna
celebrate tonight here's my only
requirement it has to be at your house
because I ain't got no money okay how
about my house where
yes he's koi to our Greg and John right
every comic corner I'm like where's the
milk
no you've been acting weird about Stevie
all day
I think you might be jealous of course
I'm jealous I was never hiding that
what do you want me to say Boyle I've
been trying to include you in this all
day long I forgot you that one time but
I made up for it you're supposed to be
my friend I'm an adult man I can have
two close friends hell I can have three
close friends you would oh you're
pushing it Stevie planted the drugs I
looked in that dishwasher before him and
it was empty you guys should go get your
ears pierced together invite Brad it'll
be smart not smart so joke's on you damn
it none of you guys can get any of these
words right swirlc I know you planted
the drugs at ozarov's place what Charles
checked the dishwasher and he didn't see
any drugs yeah well they were there I
guess you just missed them probably busy
hiking up his pants above his belly
button I wish I was like Charles he's a
good cop and an honest person and when
we go on stakeouts we do listen to Tony
Braxton and it's super sad and it's
awesome I can't believe I'm saying this
Stevie but I gotta report you oh did you
just Donkey Kong punch me it's not
enough room to regular punch you
yep yep
what's going on he did plant the drugs
you trusting me
son of a [ __ ] I hope there's room this
fight for three there's not
you have a 2 30 meeting with small head
big body I forgot to take his nail da
Braeburn huh
do you mind if we have a meeting here in
the office actually I do mine I just had
a bad loss on an online poker game get
back here you crap basket you're going
down oh he's a sacking paper no reason
oh
Shillings you have the right to remain a
loser nice but now legally I have to
start over Charles
no God
oh I thought we had something I had two
Paul
whoa I got your farm girl you wouldn't
oh
come on
hey Scott and Scully
how's going on here
I was arresting a dirty cop I heard you
scream out I love this yes this being
our guests from the 98 will have to
relocate again Captain you know what's
kind of weird there was no one fighting
over by the radiator you were the only
person standing
I suppose in the hubbub I may have
tripped and busted a pipe
he used my letter opener to cut his tuna
sandwich in half they were disrespectful
and had to go and yes sometimes you have
to come up with a creative solution yes
thank you
oh you know what I like this song
[Applause]
shut up
the nerve unbelievable
he's played so many cups I know wasn't
he in the chips movie with with Jake
Johnson
Chips movie or it's called let's let's
be cops chips just looked like a less
good version of lesbians
I saw Let's Be Cops and it was actually
decently funny was it John yeah it was
before you couldn't remember the title
of the movie apparently because it came
out at a similar time as chips
did it John I think I'm gonna google it
he's also he played uh murtog in the
Lethal Weapon show he did a opposite
clean Crawford
he's in the other guys yeah
because I was watching um when he showed
up I was like God I want to say Damon
Wayans but there's already a Damon
Wayans yeah and I just assume they're
all Brothers yes there are no Wayans
children and I was like oh no wait a
minute he's the son that's right all
right let's be cops and chips with three
years apart so so not that close idiot I
know I'm sorry wrong Damon Wayans chips
wanted to be 21 Jump Street everyone
knows that that's also true but so did
Let's Be Cops let's Recaps they're not
even real cop I know but it wants to
exist in that same vein of of bantery it
always plays this guy childish foolish
actually I didn't see the Lethal Weapon
show so I don't know what it was like on
this grumpy if he was the straight man
was he was talking look it up before I'm
racist
uh I believe it was him in there
he's a weapon oh thank God I'm not
racist this close to being racist you
were so close but it's okay yeah Damon
Wayans oh no actual Damon Wayans it
wasn't her talk I am kind of racist
it very much alike in a way that isn't
racist because they are direct father
and son so it makes sense that they
would look very much alike I never saw
the Lethal Weapon show I said hell no
never gonna do it don't disrespect my
melon Glover I heard it wasn't half bad
I heard it was pretty good up until that
guy was an [ __ ] who played Martin
Riggs yeah for whatever reason back back
when that was happening I wound up
reading a lot about that I still don't
know what to make of it because I don't
know it seemed like
maybe he wasn't a complete [ __ ] but I
don't know but anyway good episode
Another another solid episode here yeah
it's hard to share a space with it's
hard to share a friend John has an
errand
oh I saw her and for the first time you
what ah I I mean what I don't know who
every time he comes around just like man
there's a chemistry is there anyone in
the world named that I've never heard
that name chemistry between you two is
just it's such a different Dynamic than
our chemistry it's different yeah
it's talkative when the camera's not
wrong
[Laughter]
getting it all out in between takes
you're a poor and banter back and forth
so different in your discussions
involved in this
kind of discussion John has with someone
oh no yeah that's right that's Aaron I
don't trust him he planted the trucks
that's right oh no we gotta go take them
down hope you're watching Aaron I'm
sorry Warner
boys or whatever we're gonna be called
has to break up yeah
um but damn it's I was I was actually I
don't expect a Twist I didn't see that
coming at all they planted the drugs but
I was like
because I was I was thinking that is
such an obvious spot to hide drugs I'm
surprised I didn't find it I know yeah
and especially the ones that look like
marshmallows yeah they're giant
packaging dyed marshmallows is what they
were there's a bottle a bag of Pinks and
a bag of Blues and
so it was like other than that really
obvious thing oh my God that makes sense
the ones with the people invading the
space gotta be a [ __ ] nightmare oh
yeah I would load the situation like
that
that's that's intolerable a bunch of
idiots that'll happen when like the when
when like Warren is in town or something
like that and then like his whole
operation is going to collapse so that
he and his team we're gonna have to move
in 99 of the time when he's here he's
like hey you guys got a chair I still
haven't ordered a chair you could just
have the chair shipped here yeah I just
have a championship here and I'll gladly
put it in here
inside the door and you will be good to
go or
oh I need a camera I need a microphone
monitor do not prepared
I'm like I thought this was to be a
satellite base for a year I thought you
would have this stuff damn warm that's
why we got all these numbers
I said I'd say hi in a half hour he's
he's uh he's gonna come in and take all
the Elgato stuff that's why we got all
these things from Elgato recently is for
Warren to come and take them and use
them in the back house
that sucks man no see there you go then
Warren's uh Warren is uh is your Aaron
there you go
get along with the porn I do get a lot
more it's lovely and uh I like talking
to more
[Laughter]
yeah
well and I I mean I don't I don't uh I
talk to I I talked to Warren most when
he's here and we're in the same
situation like occasionally we'll
message or whatever but it's not it's
not the same
that's true
um and then uh yeah the
Rose is so funny
how old's Stephanie Beatrice type it in
now that we have this oh yeah let me
look it up
on this computer here that's how we're
gonna fill the void but it's funny what
else do you need to know great
situational comedy
um and yeah you don't want people it is
41 what not possible I refuse to boost
not that much older than this sure
but still I well and these are from
earlier in time too so all right she's
not 41 at the time this should look 41
now filming
that's what happens when a woman gets
older and you're famous
then even if you're aging incredibly
well people are still like no I can see
the age though and I'm gonna multiply it
by a hundred you look at Tom Cruise
you're like damn he looks amazing
if you put a female celebrity there
you're like
I had on 30 years
oh they should uh they should see it's
not called satire see a doctor I don't
know if you're gonna make it much longer
there the point is that we un barely do
that that's what I'm saying no Albert
Jennifer Anderson though I feel like a
people the people with Jeff France are
very very kind of Jennifer Aniston
movies every Jennifer Aniston vehicle of
recent memory takes a full stop break to
go she's still so hot and hasn't aged
much yeah here's a dance Montage to
prove that you see those Zoom interviews
oh
thing man a crappy webcam it doesn't
hide anything no it doesn't no no
special removals no gauze no Vaseline I
didn't know until like two months ago I
want to say when Olivia was showing me
tick tocks on just how much you can try
like people can trans is like brand new
to me instead I did not realize just how
much you can completely make yourself
look like a totally different human
being and they make it look real
via the power of makeup and I had no
idea you could do you know I was like of
course I'm gonna do that with like
prosthetics for movies and [ __ ] but just
eat a home application where you're like
no that's not that person what yeah well
it's all just about the subtleties of
like I don't know do something make your
cheeks appear a little different you
know shade your eyes so different now
when I interact with people and you know
if I ever meet someone I'll look at them
and I'll go
if I notice any makeup
who are you it might look like a
completely different human this is a
disguise someone I prefer all natural
99.99 of the time but I've yet to
experience it where I'm like whoa you're
like a completely different human but
it's possible that's the crazy part you
can do it
um anyway that's how Jennifer Aniston
does it but she's got a rocking bot at
yoga man you know what I mean I'm saying
her Reese Witherspoon oh yes to look
fresh yeah it's so fresh out of the
fresh out the
white ocean life
fresh out of fresh out of the
vagina's birthday
fresh out of legality
uh not old enough still looking fine her
and Nicole came into it but I bet
there's some of that makeup thing Nicole
Kidman's got an interview they see a lot
of men don't I mean men will do it for
the movies like Tom Cruise looks a lot
older than he actually like it's not Tom
Cruise it does look older than the
movies will make I'm not saying they're
deaging him but he's made up till yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you can not that
he looks like 25 years younger but you
know
shock shockingly how old is she 46 I
think what Reese Witherspoon she doesn't
get enough credit for keeping that
youthful appearance I don't know she is
barely changed it feels like Anyway our
skin is so tight wow she's 46. what else
is an old woman well you cause 46 is a
senior citizen right if you're a woman
if you're a woman if you're 36 is it
seniors 36 is like and depending on how
you look uh you said Nicole Kidman
looking Nicole Kidman oh she's like in
her 60s oh maybe yeah 55 55 okay I was
close wow
yeah what else we got
Charlie's there Charlie staring's a good
one yeah
she looks great still 40. 46 let's try
Jennifer Connelly from Top Gun Maverick
oh my gosh she still looks at me she
still does look spry and Youthful
Jennifer Connelly breakfast for her
dream days we've had that one scene
you know what I mean yeah 51.
Tom Cruise looks pretty age-appropriate
and Jennifer Connelly yeah yeah they're
not that far far in age give me 60 holy
[ __ ] and he's still like jumping off
that rocket ships and stuff for now I
feel like it's we're we're in the end
game now with Tom yeah yeah he's feeling
it 65 I finally made a billion dollars
can I stop now guys all right guys we've
talked about everything we wanted to
talk about
you have an off the cuff podcast no
that's our Brooklyn Nine-Nine reviews
yeah anyway guys we are here to um uh
end this video now with a patron of the
day shout out
Andrew Hayes I was looking at this and I
was like look everyone at our patreon no
matter what age they are they all look
so old every one of them you are ancient
they've all aged terribly ancient
patrons they're not shouting him out but
Michael B he's our age looks so much
older it looks so worse for wear just as
withering Soul what is life have you
seen Tales from the Crypt they based the
keeps the [ __ ] on Michael B yeah but
Andrew Hayes you're gonna age gracefully
age
through hey uh okay Andrew age
yeah there you go through eight or more
like Andrew doesn't
age because so young looking uh Andrew
you uh will always have have that
youthful quality about you I can feel it
that's right you're always going to look
five years old you're going to be one of
those adults who I see and I'm like I
know exactly what you look like as a kid
and it's just a smaller version it's
just you it's the same face and
everything you've got that quality
probably a similar hairdo fountain of
youth in your blood
I want to drink your blood yes I wanna
hold you upside down and cut your throat
into a bucket
cut off your face and wear it um yeah
Stick it to your own right around the
kitchen with it didn't tape to me
double-sided tape alien tape that face
on
and uh and yeah watch as people come up
to you and they're like oh wow what's
your secret how do you stay so so you
know uh how do you keep your skin so
tight it's easy
a staple of face to mine I borrow them
anyway Andrew
I'm sorry for how this took a turn but
Michael B I'm sorry enjoy your faces No
I'm just being sarcastic all right much
love to you Andrew you stay keep staying
sexy
[Music]